it may not immediately seem like it but
what you're looking at here is the front
line in an economic conflict and it's
conflict which could force Greece out of
the euro but even then there are good
outcomes and bad outcomes consider the
financial system and here even the best
case and the worst-case scenarios could
start to look pretty similar even if
there is a bailout and the ECB steps in
and pumps up the amount of cash going
into the system there could still be
queues outside cashpoints the bank still
could be closed for quite some time but
if there's no deal the ECB could pull
funding entirely then you can have banks
collapsing you could even have money
being confiscated from people's deposits
and full-blown panic let's assume Greece
does stay in the euro what's the
best-case scenario well it gets the
bailout for one thing it gets some of
its debt written off but you're going to
have a lot of compromises on both sides
it's going to be tough and it's going to
take some time but there's also a bad
version of that euro story Greece stays
in the single currency it gets on life
support from the European Central Bank
but not that much so it stays in a state
of permanent crisis weighing down its
prospects while it stays within the
single currency almost as a slave state
nor things particularly clear cut even
if Greece were to decide to leave the
euro and return to the drachma this is
the drachma cafe by the way they would
devalue there could be a boost in
exports they could get rid of their debt
that's the happy version of the story
and that results in a genuine boom but
there's another unhappy version of that
story the drachma Falls it devalues yes
but it keeps on devaluing just like it
did back in the bad old days pushes up
import prices people pull their money
desperately out of the country and
you're left with yet another depression
after the terrible one that's already
come and that's the thing we know what
the referendum result is what we don't
know are the other permutation does
Greece stay in the euro does it go back
to the drachma is this a story that ends
happily is it one that ends sadly what
we do know is it's going to be a very
bumpy ride